el referendo sobre la elección del fin
de la vida se ganó con un 65 2%
un momento emotivo para muchos de los
presentes nueva zelanda vota para
legalizar la eutanasia los activistas
dicen que es una victoria de la
compasión y la bondad es increíble esta
implementa increíble la muerte asistida
será legal para las personas que padecen
una enfermedad terminal y es probable
que mueran dentro de los seis meses pero
deben tener su decisión aprobada por dos
médicos ha habido un amplio apoyo a la
reforma de la eutanasia y nueva zelanda
y se esperaba que se aprobara el
referéndum pero los opositores dicen que
no tienen suficiente protección en su
lugar
ahora que ha pasado los riesgos
permanecen y por lo tanto estamos
profundamente preocupados y preocupados
por el futuro por las personas
vulnerables se espera que la legislación
que dé efecto a la votación entra en
vigor el próximo noviembre hemos visto
los resultados los márgenes del
referendo son tales que es muy poco
probable que esos resultados se anulen
nueva zelanda se unirá a un puñado de
países donde la eutanasia es legal
incluidos luxemburgo bélgica y canadá
entretanto en una votación separada no
vinculante se rechazó una propuesta para
legalizar el cannabis recreativo de
hecho estoy bastante sorprendida de que
en la era progresista en la que estamos
no haya pasado
deberíamos haber legalizado eso
absolutamente sacarlo de la tierra del
crimen y dárselo a la gente
tengo una planta en casa el resultado de
ambos referendos no se confirmará hasta
la próxima semana después de que se
incluyan las papeletas de votación en el
extranjero y las votaciones especiales